[Music]
[Applause]
o M G Taylor Swift's new album lover is
finally here and I don't think I've ever
been more excited as I keep saying this
has only happened six other times in
history our IT team has broken down all
the lyrics including what Taylor
seemingly says about Joe Alwyn and all
the other references to other celebs
like Leo DiCaprio and Katy Perry I hope
you're ready because this is going to be
a roller coaster and my roller coaster I
mean fun AF London boy is probably the
most fun there's also a little idris
elba surprise at the top we can go
driving in on my scooter but the song is
obviously about Joe
[Music]
and that's no surprise there's tons of
knives to tailors man this album to me
felt aesthetically and from like an
energetic perspective like very daytime
very sunlit fields I really just
pictured this and wrote music from a
perspective of like a much more open
free romantic whimsical place this album
in tone it's very romantic literally so
romantic I mean we've all heard the song
lover and in the song paper rings Taylor
sings about marriage once again quotes I
like shiny things but I'd marry you with
paper rings also a fun fact the themed
gift that you're supposed to give on a
first wedding anniversary is well paper
so do with that what you will but in a
surprise twist there's two break-up
tracks either inspired by other couples
and Taylor's life or maybe Taylor and
Joe broke up at one point here's the
first death by a thousand cuts and
afterglow which is even more
heartbreaking than that one if you can
even believe it
don't we Annie
[Music]
but there's also tons of fun bops to
like the song cruel summer which she
dropped an Easter egg about in the you
need to calm down video and the man
where Taylor is clearly so tired of the
double standard between men and women in
the media and I love her even more for
speaking up for herself
at one point she even makes a nod to Leo
DiCaprio in the opening song I forgot
that you existed it's clear Taylor is so
over
whichever acts that she's singing about
and a lot of people think it's Calvin
Harris quotes would have been right
there front row even if nobody came to
your show but you showed me who you are
then one magical night I forgot that you
existed oh my god this album is also
very self-reflective for Taylor like we
heard in the song the archer and also in
the final track daylight where she sings
lyrics like you got a step into the
daylight and let it go and I want to be
defined by the things that I love not
the things I hate and it's this lyric
that bands think is a nod to her
reconciliation with Katy Perry
[Music]
yeah did you hear that quote now I'm
wide awake
there's obviously so much more to dive
into this just feels like the tip of the
iceberg I want to know what you guys
think of the album so far though so
let's chat over on Twitter and for all
the latest on Taylor Swift make sure
that you keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now